hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español recientemente el
gobierno de argentina liderado por el
presidente alberto fernández estableció
mediante decreto el cupo laboral
travesti trans en el sector público del
país que garantiza un mínimo del 1% de
la totalidad de cargos y de contratos
para personas travestis transexuales y
transgéneros para dialogar sobre este
hecho histórico que transforma a la
nación sudamericana en la segunda de
américa latina después de uruguay en
tener una medida de este tipo nos
acompañe a florencia guimaraes garcía
ella es militante de travesti
integrantes de la organización furia
trabajo coordinadora también de la casa
de diana y joana un espacio de encuentro
para la comunidad travesti y trans de
argentina y también trabaja para el
centro de justicia de la mujer florencia
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
hola buenas buenas muchas gracias a
ustedes por dar el espacio por dar el
lugar a que nuestras voces travestis y
trans se difundan en todo el mundo con
estas noticias tan positivas extra de la
comunidad para colectivo pero a la
sociedad también esa es la idea
precisamente florencia de las personas
travestis transexuales y transgénero
constitución uno de los sectores de la
población mundial no que más sufre la
discriminación y también la
estigmatización y uno de los ámbitos en
los que se expresa no la vulneración de
sus derechos es precisamente el ámbito
laboral por eso te quiero preguntar en
primer lugar cómo recibiste no la
noticia del decreto del cupo laboral
travesti y trans
la recibimos con mucha emoción con
muchísima alegría porque esto tiene que
ver con una lucha de hace muchos años de
nuestro colectivo tiene que ver también
con la lucha de una compañera asesinada
que fuera amancay diana sacayán quien
llevara adelante la primer ley de cupo
laboral para la provincia de buenos
aires que lleva su nombre entonces fue
un momento de mucha emoción de responda
diana de recordar a nuestra compañera
lohana berkins quien fuera impulsora
también de la ley de identidad de género
y de pensar en todas aquellas compañeras
que hoy puedan tener un poquito no más
de esperanzas que pueden soñar con tener
acceso al trabajo y con romper esto
también que tiene que ver con que el 90%
de nosotras todavía hoy su existe de la
prostitución para poder vivir entonces
es importantísimo estamos hablando de
derechos humanos en definitiva
precisamente respecto de esto te iba a
preguntar ahora a florencia porque son
muy pocas las travestis y las personas
trans que tienen la posibilidad de
terminar
la secundaria porque son expulsadas del
sistema desde niñas ya se encuentran
expuestas a un rechazo social incluso
también al rechazo en el seno familiar
del cual muchas veces son expulsadas y
entonces bueno como decía en muchos
casos ingresan a la prostitución oa
otras actividades económicas que están
criminalizadas para poder subsistir por
supuesto este decreto las ayuda a
alejarse no de múltiples formas de
violencia que padecen quienes se dedican
a la prostitución algo que implicaría un
giro radical en sus vidas incluso puedes
salvar vidas no teniendo en cuenta que
se trata de un sector de la población
que tienen una expectativa de vida entre
los 35 y 40 años aproximadamente sí
totalmente totalmente esperamos que esto
empiece a revertir la desigualdad
estructural las violencias estructurales
a las que somos sometidos a las personas
travestis y trans como bien lo decías en
argentina pero en toda latinoamérica
edad que la expectativa de vida de las
personas travestis y trans ronda entre
los 35 y 40 años de edad y que también
somos expulsadas muchas veces de
nuestros hogares y de todas las
instituciones
niñas cuando asumimos nuestra identidad
de género desde niñas y adolescentes
cuando tendríamos que estar en el banco
en el pupitre de un colegio estamos ya
muchas veces en una esquina y después
esto se configura en estas muertes
tempranas en estos muertes evitables en
estos travesti cirios y travestis y dos
social que venimos hablando y
denunciando hace muchas décadas por eso
es algo importantísimo el acceso al
trabajo para poder erradicar todas estas
formas de violencia que son violencias
por identidad de género verdad frencia
crees que para que este decreto no para
que funcione bien hace falta también un
cambio social y cultural me refiero a si
es necesario un cambio en los ámbitos de
trabajo no para que sean tratadas como
corresponde además de que la ley sea
aplicada verdad
si la batalla debe ser cultural por
supuesto porque de nada sirven las leyes
los decretos si esto no va acompañado
por toda la población por toda la
sociedad que una sociedad que debe
abrazar que debe contener que debe tener
empatía no por aquellos sectores que
siempre hemos sido
vulnerados que se ha criminalizado no
las personas travestis y trans y
seguimos estando en la clandestinidad
seguimos siendo perseguidas
criminalizadas detenidas no por ejercer
la prostitución entonces se necesita un
gran apoyo necesitamos el apoyo de toda
la sociedad necesitamos el apoyo de
nuestras familias necesitamos que se
empiece a hablar de las personas
travestis y trans en las escuelas en
todos los espacios que habitamos porque
nosotros también somos parte de la
sociedad entonces el cambio debe ser
cultural debemos realmente visibilizar
que existimos que acá estamos que somos
parte de las familias que estamos en la
sociedad y que no solamente estamos en
ese lugar
arrojadas que es en una esquina por las
noches de las rutas en la prostitución
queremos estar atendiendo en una oficina
haciendo maestras abogadas doctoras
periodistas estando en los medios de
comunicación en todos los lugares como
cualquier persona porque en definitiva
somos personas y se juzga y se prejuzga
simplemente por nuestra identidad de
género o por nuestra orientación sexual
también entonces eso hay que empezar a
cambiar a transformar entonces por eso
es tan importante estas medidas o este
decreto de acciones positivas desde lo
simbólico también no que un gobierno le
diga a toda la sociedad nosotros
entendemos lo que atraviesa la población
travesti trans y vamos a tomar medidas
sobre esto y vamos a intentar y vamos a
llevar a cabo esta transformación social
fluencia en la pregunta anterior hacías
referencia a los niños y también en las
niñas por eso quería preguntarte también
sobre las infancias trans no porque este
decreto ayuda a dejarles un país mejor
de hecho una de las repercusiones que
tuvo
la medida fue el vídeo que se viralizó
seguramente lo has visto el de una niña
de 13 años de córdoba en argentina que
compartió su emoción cuando conoció la
noticia del decreto en el vídeo se la
veía diciendo textualmente estoy muy
feliz porque sé que en el futuro voy a
poder tener un trabajo digno sin ser
juzgada por mi género voy a poder
cumplir mi sueño de ser abogada decía
esta niña trans si es muy amos zelanda
realmente estamos muy bien seguimos muy
emocionadas porque luchamos por eso no
luchamos por las que están luchamos
también por nuestras compañeras que ya
no están porque tenemos miles de
compañeras muertas y luchamos también
por las futuras generaciones no para que
todas las próximas entrevistas trabas
trans compañeros y masculinidades trans
no tengan que subsistir de la
prostitución no tengan atravezar todas
las violencias que nosotros
atravesábamos atravesamos y
atravesábamos porque se trata de sonado
de luchar por un mundo mejor más
igualitario más equitativo donde las
personas
sean juzgadas por su identidad de género
por su orientación sexual en luchamos
por un mundo libre no donde cada quien
pueda vivir dependiendo de los
parámetros que desea sin fin todos estos
prejuicios sin persecución sin
discriminación y sin exclusión no
entonces emociona muchísimo pensar en
las infancias trans travestis en las
adolescencias en todo lo que vamos a
dejar pero también poner el foco en las
compañías que hoy están y que hoy están
subsistiendo de la prostitución y que
también merecen una oportunidad
merecemos realmente que se nos dé la
oportunidad de demostrar que realmente
podemos llegar a todos lados y que cada
vez que una compañía que ingresa a un
puesto laboral no le cambia la vida
solamente a esa compañera sino a todas
las personas ya todo el entorno que está
a nuestro alrededor es importante
realmente esto es muy muy importante
absolutamente florencia ahora hay
determinados sectores de la sociedad que
suelen señalar
a los cupos no cuotas como privilegios
ellos destacan lo que es la meritocracia
no como el motor para llegar a
determinados trabajos o puestos que le
respondes a quienes sostienen estas
ideas
si hay hay mucha controversia con eso no
con el tema de los cupos de los no cupos
de los privilegios la verdad que hay que
profundizar hay que pensar hay que tener
empatía hay que comprender que esta ley
es una ley de discriminación positiva
que no tendría que existir una ley de
cupo que las personas travestis y trans
tendríamos que poder estar en todos los
lugares que correspondan pero como somos
excluidas no nos dejan esos lugares
entonces tiene que ver con eso con
comprender la realidad de la comunidad
travesti trans verdad y que esto no es
que estábamos pidiendo un derecho
seccional simplemente porque somos
travestis y trans simplemente exigimos
que se nos tenga en cuenta y que se
tomen medidas y políticas públicas para
transformar todo esto que veníamos
hablando denunciando anteriormente una
expectativa de vida de 35 años de edad
la exclusión la expulsión tanto del
sistema laboral como del sistema
educativo como del acceso a la salud que
todavía es algo muy complejo la primer
causa de muerte de nuestra comunidad
tiene que ver con
y otras infecciones de transmisión
sexual la segunda causa de muerte sigue
siendo la aplicación de silicona
industrial de maneras clandestinas y la
tercer causa de muerte tiene que ver con
los crímenes de odio con los travestis y
dios entonces esto es realmente es muy
grave y hay que poner esto sobre la mesa
y la sociedad tiene que empezar a
escuchar por eso yo agradezco mucho esta
nota y esta participación para que esto
se escuche para que muchas personas
seguramente que están del otro lado de
sus casas no comprenden no saben lo que
atravesaron las personas travestis y
trans pero hay que pensar simplemente no
un poquitito el porque siempre cuando
hablamos de las travestis las mujeres
trans hablamos de ellas en situación de
prostitución sabemos dónde están si
están en las estas llamadas 'zonas
rojas' etcétera y no reflexionamos un
minuto y decimos porque no hay personas
travestis y trans que sean maestras de
mis hijos que atiendan en el negocio
cuando voy a la panadería cuando voy a
la escuela estén dando una clase son
abogadas son diputadas legisladoras
porque estas personas no llegan y si
sabemos gran parte de la sociedad sabe
dónde encontrarnos por las noches no
entonces hay que reflexionar y hay que
tener en cuenta lo que nosotras venimos
denunciando que muchas veces esos
prejuicios tienen que ver con la
ignorancia con el no saber y muchas
veces también hay una cuota de
el pensamiento conservador de este
pensamiento heteronormativo no que
siempre todo se basa en hombre mujer
mamá papá y quedamos por fuera todas
aquellas personas que no cabemos en esos
parámetros y que somos parte y que
también somos familia y que tenemos
otras maneras de vivir de amar de desear
y de movernos en el mundo porque en
definitiva existimos hay una diversidad
enorme de géneros de etnias de
corporalidad es se trata de eso no de
inclusión gerencia y mara garcía
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 ha sido
realmente un placer este diálogo muchas
gracias a ustedes un abrazo enorme a
nuestra audiencia la despedimos y le
invitamos a quedarse con nosotros porque
hay mucho más en el resto de nuestra
programación y como siempre les decimos
en france24 punto com
[Música]